اهلا بكم اعلن مجلس صيانه الدستور في
ايران القائمه النهائيه لمرشحي الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المتضمنه لثمانيه اسماء اغلبيتها
الساحقه من المحافظين ئمه استبعدت مئات
المرشحين ابرزهم هاشمي رفسنجاني واسفنديار
رحيم مشائي ما خلف ردود فعل واسعه داخل
البلاد نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في
محورين ما تقوله القائمه النهائيه لمرشحي
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الايرانيه التحولات التي يعيشها المشهد
السياسي الايراني على وق الانتخابات
الرئاسيه انتهى المشوار بالنسبه لمئات
المرشحين حتى قبل ان يبدا وبات معلوما
للناخبين الايرانيين ان اختيارهم بات
محصورا في ثمانيه مرشحين خمسه منهم
محافظون في المقابل اسقط قرار مجلس يانه
الدستور ورقه الرئيس الاسبق هاشمي
رفسنجاني من يد الاصلاحيين وحرم اح مجاد
من المراغنه على مرشحه المقرب اسفنديار
رحيم مشائي في خطوه رفعت سقف التوقعات بان
الرئيس الايراني المقبل سيكون على الارجح
محافظا كشور اعلام در اجرا ماده عرفوا
اخيرا خمسه محافظين معتدل واصلاح واضح ان
المفاجات ليست اختصاص مجلس صيانه الدستور
فالترجيح التي اجازها المجلس ينتمي معظم
اصحابها الى معسكر يحظى بدعم النظام يكفي
ان بين هؤلاء المحافظين سعيد جليلي امين
مجلس الامن القومي وكبير المفاوضين في
الملف النووي وصفه محلل سياسي ايراني بانه
محافظ اكثر من الاخرين يؤمن اكثر بالقيم
الثوريه وهو اقرب الى اصحاب القرار في
السلطه مقرب اخر من مرشد الجمهوريه
الايرانيه انه مستشاره ووزير الخارجيه
السابق علي اكبر ولايتي وفي الصف المحافظ
عينه رئيس بلديه طهران محمد باقر قاليباف
المقرب كالاخرين من المرشد علي خامنئي لا
يبدو الامر صدفه فليس في مواجهه المحافظين
اسماء معتدله او اصلاحيه من العيار
الثقيل لا يستغرب كثيرون ان وضعت مئات
الترشيحات على قائمه المنع بينها اسماء
بارزه يتقدمها رئيس ايران الاسبق ورئيس
مجلس تشخيص م محه النظام هاشمي
رفسنجاني يرتاب المحافظون المتشددون من
رفسنجاني منذ انتقد قمع احتجاجات عام 2009
التي اعقبت فوز احمد نجاد بولايته الثانيه
وبعين الريبه ايضا ينظرون الى رحيم مشائي
مستشار الرئيس المغادر احمدي نجاد وصهره
بدعوه انه يسعى الى تهميش حكم رجال الدين
استبعاد مشائي من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
وصفه احمدي نجاد بالظالم وقال انه سيطلب
تدخل المرشد الاعلى شخصيا في القضيه يدرك
احمدي نجاد ان ايه الله علي خامنئي وحده
محول الغاء قرار مجلس صيانه الدستور ويدرك
كثير من الايرانيين ان قدوم رئيس لا يوالي
النظام السياسي ولاء مطلقا اشبه
بالمستحيل موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع امير
موساوي مدير مركز الدراسات الاسترا يجيه
والدوليه بطهران من بيروت اسعد حيدر
الخبير في الشؤون الايرانيه وهنا معنا في
الاستوديو الدكتوره فاطمه صمادي الباحثه
في الشؤون الايرانيه بمركز الجزيره
للدراسه اهلا بضيوفي الكرام وابدا بضيفي
من طهران امير موسوي امير قبل ان نخوض
فيما استطاع ان يتجاوز
غربال مجلس صيانه الدستور نتكلم عن مصير
مشائي هل ستنحصر القائمه في هذه الاسماء
الثمانيه ام ان هناك مجال ان ينضم اليها
اسفندي الرحيم
بشاق نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم ما زالت
هناك فرصه يعني ربما حتى يوم الاحد القادم
ربما
ستتبع النهائيه لهذه القائمه لانه من حق
المرشد الاعلى الامام الخامنائي ان يتدخل
في هذا الامر حسب الماده 110 من الدستور
الايراني وهي من صلاحيات ولايه الفقيه ان
يحسمها هذا الامر شخصيا كما حسمه قبل اربع
سنوات او ثمان سنوات عندما وافق على ادخال
بعض الاصلاحيين الى قائمه الترشيح وخاصه
نحن نرى اليوم ان القائمه تحتوي على ثمان
مرشحين اذا هناك مجال لاضافه مرشحين اخرين
وعاده الانتخابات الرئاسيه تتضمن قائمه من
عشره اسماء حسب التجربه السابقه فلذا ربما
يدخل فيها اما ايه الله رفسنجاني او السيد
رحيم مشا ربما ايض فيها وان سؤالي موجه
الى الاستاذ ح اسعد حيدر ماذا لو لم يتم
انضمام اسفنديار مشائي الى هذه القائمه
ماذا عن رد فعل الرئيس احمدي نجاد في هذه
الحال من باب
التوقع على المدى القصير لا اتوقع ان يقوم
باي حركه خصوصا وان الحرس الثوري جزء
اساسي مما يحصل لكن الخطوره في احمد نجاد
او مشائي تحديدا امتلاكهما
لملفات تتعلق بالفساد على اعلى المستويات
و في الاداره
السياسيه السؤال الكبير هل يتجرا احمد
نجاد في لحظه معينه على الكشف عن
هذه الملفات وهل يذهب في النهايه الى
صدام كبير مع المرشد خصوصا وان مشائي حاول
ان يسترضي
المرشد في اللحظه الاخيره ويقول انه اعظم
شخصيه في العالم وفي التاريخ اعتقد ان ما
حصل حتى الان هو زلزال كبير في اقصاء
هاشمي رفسنجاني ومشاق ويجب
انتظار الزلازل الارتداديه التي ستحصل
سواء على المدى القصير او المدى المتوسط
في ايران خصوصا بما يتعلق بالتوازنات
الداخليه وموقف المعا عن عن هذه التوازنات
استاذ اسعد عن هذه التوازنات لنقرا هذه
القائمه مع الدكتوره فاطمه الموجود الان
هذه الاسماء الثمانيه سواء انضم اليها
مشائي او لم ينضم ما اهم ما لاحظته في هذه
القائمه الملاحظه الاساسيه في هذه القائمه
هي
ملاحظتين اولاهما هي عوده ولايتي وهذا من
الممكن ان يقرا ب بمؤشرات كبيره على صعيد
السياسه الخارجيه وايضا وجود سعيد جليلي
في هذه القائمه ايضا يقرا له قراءات عديده
تتعلق بالشان الداخلي الايراني وايضا على
صعيد الملف النووي والمفاوضات مع الخارج
هاتان الشخصيتان بتوقعي سيكونان صاحب
تاثير كبير على مجريات العمليه الانتخابيه
وكل شخصيه تترك يعني تعطي انطباعات مهمه
على صعيد الخارطه الانتخابيه بشكل بشكل
كبير ايضا على صعيد التيار الاصولي نفسه
التنافس داخل التيار الاصولي يعني تعطي
انطباع ان المنافسه على منصب الرئاسه
ستكون محصوره داخل التيار الاصولي هناك
ايضا قال باف لا يمكن التقليل من من شانه
لكن على الصعيد الاصلاحي لا يمكن التعويل
كثيرا على يعني الشخصيات المتقدمه حتى
روحاني بتجربته الكبيره على صعيد الملف
النووي الايراني الاى انه داخل التيار
الاصولي لا يحظى بتاثير كبير امير موسوي
من خلال تجربه الرئيس احمدي نجاد هناك
اسئله اصبحت تطرح بشكل مباشر فيما يتعلق
بمن سيكون الرئيس القادم وعلاقته بالمؤسسه
الثقل بدايه من المرشد وانتهاء بمؤسسه
الامنيه باعتقادك الى اي مدى هذه المساله
روعيت في من في هذه الاسماء الثمانيه
المطروحه للشعب الايراني حتى يختار
منها نعم بصوره عام نظره سريعه الى الى
هذه الاسماء الثمانيه لو حسمت بصوره
نهائيه انا اعتقد ان هذا هذه الاسماء
تحتوي على شيئين اساسيين وهو وهي ان
الاصلاح يعني تيار الاصلاحي المعتدل دخل
بقوه الى هذه القائمه وكذلك الاصوليين
المعتدلين دخلوا الى هذه القائمه وحذف من
الطرفين المتشددين يعني هناك لا نرى اي
متشدد في هذه القائمه اذا على ما يبدو ان
الامور تتجه نحو الاعتدال في الداخل
والخارج وفي القضايا الاقتصاديه وخاصه ما
يرتبط بالم طن الايراني وكذلك ما يرتبط
بالملفات الساخنه الاقليميه والدوليه انا
اعتقد ان هذا الامر لو حسم بهذه الصوره
ستتجه الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه نحو
الاعتدال في كل الملفات فلذا ربما هذه
خطوه جديده ان كان حصل على الاكثريه من
الاصلاحيين او من المحافظين او الاصوليين
الاثنين الطرفين هم من المعتدلين ومن
المتفاهمين جدا مع مع مقام ولايه الفقيه
في ايران ومع المؤسسات الدينيه وم
المؤسسات العسكريه والامنيه وكذلك الجميع
متفق على موضوع حق ايران بامتلاك تقنيه
نوويه سلميه وعدم الانصياع
لل السياسات الاستكباري وانما الطرفين
يرغبان بان يتجهان نحو التفاهم الدبلوماسي
بالنديه وبالتعامل ومن دون خضوع او خنوع
الى املاءات استكبار انا اعتقد هذا الا
اشرت الى الى موضوع الى موضوع مهم وهو
موضوع الاقتصاد وهو حاضر بقوه كمؤشر
وكمعظم وهنا سؤالي موجه للاستاذ اسعد حيدر
من بين الاسماء المطروحه في هذه القائمه
التي ليست نهائيه الى الان في انتظار ما
سيفضل الامر فيما يتعلق
بمشا الى اي مدى فعلا هذا البعد سيكون
مؤثرا ولمصلحته من ضمن الاسماء المطروحه
برايك اذا فهمت السؤال جيدا فان ان برايي
اولا الاصلاحيين موجودين ب يعني وجودهم
شكلي مثل ما ان المعتدلين في المحافظين
وجودهم شكلي الوجود الحقيقي هو للمحافظين
المتشددين
وابرزهم المرشحون الاربعه
اي سعيد جليلي ومحمد قاليباف وعلي ولايتي
وغلام حداد عادل المعركه برايي ستنحصر في
النهايه بين سعيد جليلي ومحمد قاليباف اي
بين ممثل الحرس وممثل الامن اذا اردنا ان
نبسط الامر لان سعيد
جليلي صحيح انه رجل الملف النووي وانه في
الخارج معتدل
لكن لكنه في الداخل متشدد وهو ايض تتوقع
هل تتوقع استاذ اسعد هل تتوقع منافسه بين
الرجلين ام تحالف في مرحله
ما نعم اعتقد ان المنافسه الحقيقيه ستكون
بين سعيد جليلي ومحمد جالي باف ولايه
الدكتور ولايتي نعرف انه مريض وانه كان
يحضر ل لولايه انتقاليه اما غلام حداد
عادل فقد اعلن انه مستعد للانسحاب لمصلحه
جليلي اذا وجد انه سيربح فاذا هو حضر
المشهد لانسحابه من الانتخابات المعركه
الانتخابيه هي داخل البيت المحافظ المتشدد
وليست خارجه وكل ما هو خارج هذا البيت هو
شكلي لاعطاء الانتخابات قوه دفع
شعبيه سنرى كيف ستكون والاهم من ذلك ان
هذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه هي عده انتخابات
في واحده لانه يجب علينا ان لا ننسى انه
توجد انتخابات بلديه وانه جرى اقصاء
الكثير من المرشحين الاصلاحيين فاذا ايران
مقبله على تشدد في الداخل وربما على
انفتاح في الخارج تحت
اشراف المرشد مباشره وباد الحرس الثوري
واذا صح التعبير بكل بساطه فقط لافهم منك
بشكل افضل استاذ اسعد انت تقول بان ايران
مقبله على تشدد في الداخل وانفتاح في
الخارج ام
العكس نعم سالتك قلت بان ايران مقبله على
تشدد في الداخل وانفتاح في الخارج ام
العكس انفتاح في الداخل وربما تشدد في
الخارج لو كان الانفتاح في الداخل وارد
لكان سمح لرشم رفسنجاني بالترشح لانه كان
صاحب خطاب معتدل ولم يسمح له وكان قد
انتقد بقوه
بقسوه امساك الحارس الثوري مؤخرا بالسلطه
وبراك بمفاصل الاقتصا ضيه المشكله
الاساسيه ان الايران اليوم بحاجه لانضباط
داخل البيت المحافظ المتشدد وعلى مساحه
البلد لان حتى جليلي يعتبر والاخرون
يعتبرون ان هناك هجمه خارجيه على ايران
وان ايران في في في مرحله تفاوض على موقع
الاقليمي طيب بما انك بما انك اشرت استاذ
اسعد بما انك اشرت الى اسم جليلي وهو من
الاسماء
الحاضره بقوه وبعض من يضيف له بعض النقاط
في اطار الترشيحات بحكم علاقته ب ما يقال
عن علاقته بالمرشد وايضا وهن سؤالي موجه
للدكتوره فاطمه يقال بان جليلي من بين ما
يزيده قوه في حضوره بانه مع سياسه التشدد
خاصه وهو الذي يعلم بشكل دقيق ما يتعلق
بالملف النووي الايراني ولكنه مع نوع من
الانفتاح في الداخل الايراني هل هذا صحيح
برايك هو ليس بهذا الشكل يعني لا يمكن ان
نتحدث عن يعني مرشح من الممكن ان يحدث
انفتاح في الداخل او حاله من الاسترخاء في
الداخل امام المشكلات الداخليه المستعصيه
الان في ايران نحن نتحدث عن ملف اقتصادي
صعب نتحدث عن رئيس سيستلم تركه اقتصاديه
ثقيله نتحدث عن تضخم وصل الى
40% يعني بتصريحات شبه رسميه هذه التركه
الثقيله على الصعيد الاقتصادي الداخلي
اضافه الى حاله الا احتقان السياسي
المستمره منذ 2009 تجعل من يعني من محاوله
اعطاء تهدئه للشان الداخلي مساله تتجاوز
الرئيس بشكل كبير اضافه الى مساله مهمه
على صعيد سعيد جليلي سعيد جليلي خبرته
الداخليه قليله جدا هو هو يعني من الماخذ
الكبيره عليه حتى من من قبل التيار
الاصولي نفسه انه صاحب تجربه يعني قليله
جدا على الصعيد الداخلي لم يتولى مناصب
داخليه مهمه هو لديه منصب على صعيد الملف
النووي الايراني لكن على الداخل الايراني
هناك انتقادات كبيره ان الرجل ليس لديه
خبره اداريه ليتمكن من اداره الملف
الداخلي بشكل كبير وهذه نقطه في غايه
الاهميه يعني التركه الثقيله لا ت لا
تتوقف عند الشان الاقتصادي فقط هناك حاله
احتقان مستمره على الصعيد السياسي هناك
حاله اقصاء رفسنجاني اقصاء رفسنجاني سيترك
تبعات كبيره لا يمكن قراءته بشكل بسيط على
الساحه الايرانيه خاصه ان رفسنجاني قبل ان
يترشح قال بالحرف الواحد انني لن اترشح
بدون مباركات المرشد ونشرت مواقع
قريب امتثل نعم امتثل لقرار المجلس ولكن
على الصعيد الداخلي هو يمتثل رفسنجاني
يعني هو من اباء
الثوره يعني من المتوقع ان يمتثل لقرار
مجلس صيانه
الدستور لكن الامال العريضه التي التي
رسمها كثيرون على عوده
رفسنجاني يعني ستترك تبعات اضافه لمساله
مساله على الصعيد عفوا الصعيد الخارجي انا
يعني ارى ان التشدد سيكون عنوان المرحله
القادمه في ايران على الصعيد الداخلي وعلى
الصعيد الخارجي واضافه اخيره انا اتوقع ان
تكون الحلقه المقربه من المرشد والتي يعني
لها صفه امنيه او من الحرس الثوري هي
صاحبه النفوذ الاكبر في المرحله القادمه
في ايران طيب بعد فاصل قصير سنناقش ا هذه
الانتخابات في بعدها وعلاقتها بمستقبل
الخارطه السياسيه في ايران على ضوء الظروف
التي تكتنف الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
تستعد البلاد لخوضها قريبا ابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تحاول تقديم قراءه للقائمه النهائيه
لمرشحي الانتخابات الرئاسيه في ايران
واوجد تحيه لضيوفي هنا في الاستوديو وكذلك
في بيروت وفي طهران من طهران امير موسوي
اشارت الدكتوره معي في الاستديو الى
العامل الامني فيما يتعلق بمن من قد يكون
رئيس ايران السابق كنت قبل قليل قد تكلمت
انت واشرت بسؤالي الى ضيفي في بيروت عن
البعد الاقتصادي ماذا عن الموجه الاساسي
لمن سيكون الرئيس القادم في ايران
برايك نعم طبعا هناك ما زالت
ال الترشيحات يعني فيها غرب كبير باعتبار
ان المحافظين ربما سيقدمون شخص واحد مقابل
اربع اربع شخصيات الان ربما متفقين على
على شخصيه واحده وهي يعني الدكتور ولايتي
الدكتور ولايتي و قالي باف وحداد عادل
وسعيد جليلي هؤلاء الاربعه ربما سيتفقون
على تقديم شخص واحد وينسحب الاخرين وربما
كذلك يتم التوافق بين عارف وحسن روحاني
ويبقى محسن رضائي وكذلك محمد غرضي فانا
اعتقد ان ربما الئ القائمه ستتقلص
وتتبين الامور اكثر وضوحا هناك اتجاه نحو
التمركز على سعيد جليلي من قبل المحافظين
وكذلك في معسكر الاصلاحيين توجه نحو
التمركز على شخصيه الشيخ حسن روحاني وكذلك
بقاء محسن رضائي القائد الحرس الثوري
السابق والان هو يدير باعتباره سكرتير
مجمع تشخيص مصلحه النظام ومحمد غرضي الذي
ابتعد عن السياسه منذ زمن بعيد كان وزيرا
في عهد مير حسين موسوي طبعا في اوائل
الثوره الاسلاميه في عهد العهد الاول فلذا
نعتقد ان هناك تغييرات ستط اذا ما حسمت
هذه القائمه طبعا هناك توقعات ان تضاف
اليها شخصيتين ربما ياتي رفسنجاني ومشاق
في اخر الامر لكن اذا حسمت هذه القائمه
بالاعداد الثمانيه ربما ستت قلص كذلك الى
عدد اقل ويصل ربما الى اربع اشخاص لكن
الاتجاه نحو القضايا الامنيه والاقتصاديه
الجميع وضح برنامجهم انا باعتقادي ك يعني
يعني كم مراقب لكل ما حصل من برامج
للمرشحين انا اعتقد ان السيد قالي باف
لديه برنامج اقتصادي واضح وكذلك
السيد سعيد جليلي اوضح ماذا يمكن ان يكون
له من برنامج لانه هو بالاضافه الى انه
مفاوض كبير في مجال الملف النووي الايراني
لكنه يراس مجلس الامن القومي اذا لديه
المعلومات خلال السنوات الماضيه معلومات
دقيقه عن ما يجري في البلد وهو ممثل
المرشد الاعلى في مجلس الامن القومي
والسكرتير الاعلى لهذا المجلس اذا لديه كل
الملفات الامنيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه
الداخليه والخارجيه باعتبار المجلس الامن
القومي في ايران لديه موقع مهم جدا في هذه
القضايا انا اعتقد ان الامور الاقتصاديه
واضحه المعالم هناك حلول وضع
وكذلك القضايا الامنيه طبعا لا مشكله
امنيه في داخل ايران انا اعتقد الامر
المهم للمرشح الجديد والذي يتراس ايران
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه لاحقا
امامه ملفات مهمه اقليميه ودوليه وعلى
راسها الملف السوري ملف العراق ملف
الول الجوار في منطقه الخليج الفارسي
اعتقد هذه مهمه جدا في المرحله القادمه
والعلاقات الامريكيه الايرانيه طبعا هذا
كله يحتاج الى تنسيق بصوره كبيره وواسعه
مع المرش هذا هذا فيما يتعلق بالملفات
الخارجيه وهنا سؤالي موجه ضيفي في بيروت
الاستاذ اسعد حيدر الى اي مدى استبعاد
رفسنجاني واسفنديار رحيم مشائي يجعلنا
نتوقع شكل العلاقه المطلوبه من الرئيس
القادم بين مؤسسه الرئاسه وبين مؤسسه
المرشد يعني نحن نعرف ان اولا ابعاد رفس
جاني عن الترشيح فيهي الشيء الشخصي طوال
30 سنه رفسنجاني كان يقول سرا و وعلانيه
انه هو الذي
صنع علي خامنئي وهو الذي اوصله الى منصب
المرشد اليوم في قرار ليس
مسؤولا مسؤوليه مباشره خامنئي عنه
وانما المجلس الخبراء جرى فصله واخراجه من
المش
السياسي
تقريبا الرسمي يبقى المشهد الاخر لا نعرف
كيف ستطور الامور اما مشائي فانه مشكله
اساسيه انه كان سيكون
ال المثل الروسي او التجربه الروسيه بين
ميديفيت وبوتين ولذلك كان الجميع يخاف من
عوده نجاد على عبر جسر اي مشائي اذا مشائي
طبعا فلذلك جر بعدهما اليوم السؤال
الاساسي الذي يطرح على المرشح الذي س ياتي
سينتخب رئيسا للجمهوريه هو كيفيه علاقته
مع المرشد سواء كان
اي جليلي او قاليباف او ولايتي او غلام
حداد عادل فان علاقتهم مع المرشد جيده جدا
وهم يعرفونه ويعرفهم منذ فتره طويله علي
ولايتي هو مستشاره لشؤون خارجيه منذ اكثر
من ع سنوات غلام حداد عادل تربطه علاقه
مصاهره مع
ابن المرشد علي
خمني اذا العلاقه المفترضه ان طوال الاربع
سنوات القادمه ستكون جيده لكن وحتى ممتازه
لكن السؤال الاساسي وانا الذي اريد ان
اركس عليه هو ماذا سي يريد الحرس الثوري
من هذه السلطه هل من الرئاسه القادمه فقط
لان الوقت يداهمنا استاذ اسعد اعتذر منك
وق فقط سؤال ل الدكتوره فاطمه برايك
العلاقه تكون جيده بين هذا في ما يتعلق
بمؤسسه الرئاسه ومؤسسه المرشد لكن برايك
دكتوره فاطمه ما اهم ما سيطرى على المشهد
السياسي في ايران بهذه القائمه وبرئيس
القادم برايك باختصار هو باختصار شديد ال
يعني القائمه ما زالت مفتوحه يعني لم تغلق
الى الان من الممكن ان يعني ان يصدر قرار
يسمى يعني حكم حكومتي بال عند في ايران
وهو قرار من المرشد يفتح القائمه ويؤكد
ترشيح يعني يعيد ترشيح مشاي يصادق على
ترشيح مشاي وايضا رفسنجاني وهناك يعني
سابقه في ذلك في في انتخابات
2005 تدخل المرشد
واقر ترشيح الدكتور معين من التيار
الاصلاحي وهذه يعني سابقه من الممكن ان
تتكرر هناك ايضا مخاطبات ل للمرشد على هذا
الصعيد من يعني يعني في رساله من زهراء
مصطفى وابنه الامام الخميني قالت للمرشد
فيها انه يعني هذا على صعيد المفاجات التي
من الممكن ان تحصل اذا اغلقت هذه القائمه
يبقى الوضع مفتوحا يبقى لا اذا اغلقت
القائمه على الثمان مرشحين الذين اعلن
عنهم باختصار شديد فهذا يعني اما انقسام
داخل التيار الاصولي وبقا مرشحين متعددين
وبالتالي التنافس سيكون
ب اكر ضيوفي هنا في الاستوديو وكذلك من
بيروت وكذلك من طهران ب تنتهي هذه الحلقه
الى اللقاء باذن
الله